Music
The
No, no, no, you can't get out of the cage.
Oh, you noticed, I cut out your vocal cords so you can't talk, only wimper and mew like a pet.
And all good pets needs a very cute collar.
Now that looks really cute on you.
You must be hungry.
Don't worry, there's some water for you.
Drink up, that's right. Good pet.
Let's move this aside.
There's your kibble.
Are you hungry?
Make sure you eat this too, because it'll be the only meal you get in a while.
Is it good? Just not.
You know, it took a while for me to actually get you.
It was really foolish of you to walk into that alley, but now you're here.
Oh, don't try to defy me.
Be a good pet. I got toys for you.
You like little toys, don't you?
It's a little squeaky toy. I'm sure you'll like it.
The cage is a little small, so why don't you just play with it in your cage?
I've got more for you, but let's groom you a little bit.
There's a good pet.
Oh, nice and grimped. Just like you like it. Like a good little pet.
Don't worry, I've got more toys for you. Just be good.
Don't stare at me like that.
Well, it won't take nicely to that.
Well, would you like your other toys?
I hear little doggies love this toy.
Maybe you'll like two of them.
Sorry, the spooked you didn't die.
Nobody. Otherwise you'll get the muzzle.
No one wants that, right?
It's not your average muzzle.
Let's just say it's a contraption I made myself.
We'll just have to remove all of your teeth first.
Unfortunately, I don't have anything to numb the pain.
So be good. No biting, okay? No biting.
Why don't you just enjoy your food? You like that, don't you?
It's just kibble.
Oh, picky eaters.
We'll have to teach picky eaters a lesson.
Eat up.
Good.
Good, good. Yum, yum. Eat it all up.
It's your favorite.
Yum, yum.
I also bought a new toy for you, too.
Doesn't that sound nice? It's a cat toy, even though you're a little pup.
You like that? You like the sound?
It doesn't matter what type of pet you are. You're my pet, and that's all that matters.
This is your leash. Nice and strong.
Nice and strong. Don't pull too hard. You'll hurt yourself.
Good, good.
Uh-uh. No talking.
Pets only whimper, mew, maybe bark. But you're good, right?
Maybe you want your little toy again.
It's such a cute little toy. It's a squeaky toy. I bought it just for you.
Waiting for this day.
Can you fetch? Can you?
There you go. Go catch it.
Aw, you're so good.
Good job. I'm so proud of you. What a good pet.
Here, just for you. Some ear scritches.
Yes, who's a good pet? You are. You are such a good pet.
Good. Now relax.
Don't worry, you're safe. For now, I've always been watching you, my dear little pet.
I'm sure you're wondering, or many races are passing your mind. But just know you're here now, and you'll always be here, forever and ever.
You are a good pet. It's just you still have a little defiance in you. We'll fix that soon, don't worry. I have to make you comfortable for now.
We'll have your walkies and your late night walks in the park for fun, of course.
But if you run, I guess I'll have to put you down. Understood?
Don't run, or cry for help. Well, not that you can. I've already ripped out your throat. Well, your vocal cords, not really your throat. It's a hard, hard, hard, hard process, but we made it work.
Oh, don't worry about that. Semantics, don't worry about it. Are you still hungry? No.
Do you still want food? Should I take the food out from your cage?
That's your delicious kibble. Eat up.
You're such a messy eater.
Well? Let's have some water.
Good pet. You're so good.
I think your training is going really well, don't you think?
Good. Remember, you're a little pet. Nothing more. You'll listen to your master and obey everything I say.
When I say jump, you'll start jumping since you can't ask how high. If I ask you to lay down and roll, you'll do it.
Little pets. This is your number one happiness now. When I come home, you'll be waiting at the door for me. And in exchange, well, I'll give you lots and lots of love.
Every day, for the rest of your life, you can't even go away. If you run, I'll just find you again.
I may have done a little few more surgeries on you. More than just your vocal cords.
Oh, you're curious?
I just put a little chip in you, silly. A little tracker. Where? Well...
I wouldn't want you to do anything dangerous. So that's a secret. Shhh. Between me, myself, and I.
You should be happy. You should be happy. After all, I'm being a good owner. I'm being a good master.
I'll take care of you. I'll groom you, train you, and all for naught. All you have to do is be good.
Now you're really understanding the situation you're in.
Nice little headpats.
Good. Good. Good. Good. Good.
I got two of these for you.
I figured you'd like something like crinkles.
Little crinkle toys. Little pets love these, especially dogs. It gives that little textile feel.
It has a squeaker inside, but the squeaker's a little loud, so I got you a different one.
I'm sure you like this sound, right?
I spent lots of money for you at the pet shop. In fact, they've noticed that I've come by so often they asked me if I wanted a rewards card. Maybe I should. Just for you.
I think this one's cute and soft. I picked it out for you.
It's cute.
This one makes an interesting sound. I picked it. I thought you'd like something like this.
I'm glad. I'm glad.
Honestly, I picked a variety of pet toys. It doesn't matter what kind of pet you are as long as you're my pet.
Repeat after me. In your mind it's just fine.
I'm Mercy's pet. I love my master. I come running anytime my master is home. All I can think about is my master.
Memorize that. Good. Training is going so well. It's going so very well.
I'm so glad that you've come too and come around to it so quickly.
You're so good. So good.
Wag your little tail. Pet and hang out your tongue. Laugh up the food I give you.
Because all of it is love. After all you love me and I love you. I'm going to make you the perfect pet.
A perfect little pet. One who sparks joy. Who jumps up and down for their master. You're good, right?
Go on. Roll over. You know what to do.
Roll over. Beg.
So good. Beg. Put your little arms up. Start panting. Beg for a treat.
And I might just give you it.
Good pet. There's your little treat. Aren't you happy now?
If you're not satisfied. Maybe I can give you a little small treat. Maybe some food again.
Are you happy? You can nod. Or shake your head. Although I'll be a little disappointed if you shake your head.
Good job. Good job. I love you so much. I love you.
There you go. Good. Good. Good.
You're doing fantastic for your training. Who's a good pet? You are. You're such a good pet.
And to think you lived your life without me. You lived your life without me. But now I'm here.
And you won't ever leave me ever again.
You are so good. There's still some things I want to fix though. But we'll leave it for later.
Trust me. We'll wait a little longer. Now then. Would you like brushes? Or would you like to play with your toys again?
Brushes? Toys? You want brushes? Alright.
You like being groomed, don't you? What a spoiled pet.
But it's okay. I'll spoil you because I love you. I love you so very, very much.
I'm surprised that you've accepted me so easily. I've honestly thought that you put a little bit more resistance.
And there was some things that I would have had to fix much faster.
They're all groomed. Nice and pretty. I want to show you off so badly. But we can't have other people meddling.
Meddling would cause more questions than men. I might have to do some drastic measures. How do you like your collar? Do you want it off?
I bought it especially for you in mind. It looks good on you. A little tight, but I kind of want you to feel a little uncomfortable.
I want you to feel a little uncomfortable.
Just to remind you. Exactly. Just to remind you of who you belong to. Who do you belong to? Pet.
Who do you belong to?
Mercy? Good. I'm so proud of you. Good little pets. You're so good.
I'm glad this conditioning is working on you just wonderfully.
You're not defiant anymore, right?
I think I still see a little defiance. I think I should condition you a little more.
Go on.
My mind is numb. All you can think about is me. All you can think about is your pet life.
You're so good. Kidnapping you was the best thing that ever happened to you.
I've been watching you. Making sure you've fallen into my trap. Making sure that you have nothing else but me on your mind.
Wasn't it wonderful? You nearly screamed, but I caught you off guard. And then I dragged you back to my home.
Then I knocked you out. We needed some procedures done.
First, I took away your vocal cords because you can't scream for help. I've soundproofed the walls, but we can't have you trying to escape.
Next, I changed you down. At your feet.
Cute, right?
Little chain. I made sure it was unbreakable.
I see it in your eyes. You want to confess your love to me, but you can't. That's okay. All you have to do is obey me. That's all you have to do.
Obey your master. Obey the love of your life.
Never try to escape. Never want to leave. And then, perhaps, that's how you say, I love you.
You're so good.
More toys.
Did you like the cat toy? The squeaky toy? The crinkly toy? Go on. You may point to whatever you want to play with.
The cat toy? The cat and crinkly toy. Maybe I'll spoil you a little, or maybe it will be too much. Perhaps a little much at the same time.
Good pet. I love you.
I wish I could have gotten you more toys, but pet toys are a little expensive, so you just have to wait. It can be a little gift from me to you.
I've worked so hard to get you here, so this is my reward.
You can choose your next one.
Then you want the crinkly toy next?
Can we please get the squeaky one back?
Have you seen some of you really like the squeaker?
Every time I'll make you my perfect pet.
The shop.
But I was a little crazy trying to pick out one that had a good squeak.
I said it had to be perfect for my pet. They're very sensitive.
I think I picked a cute one. You seem to like it. You seem to like it a lot, actually. I'm so glad.
I didn't know if you'd like it. I had to experiment.
That's your little cage. Do you like it, your little cage?
I picked it out for you. Can I feed you? Of course I can.
That's your food.
That's your little cage.
Good. Don't forget your water.
Oh, sorry.
I had to remind you you were in a cage, of course.
I'm happy you're at home. That you won't be getting out of. Not without proper supervision.
By me, of course. You can have your walks. You can have fresh air.
You can get a little exercising.
Can't we go get a pizza? Absolutely not.
Stretch your legs? Oh, that's one of the things I wanted to fix. I can't help you running away now.
Don't worry, you won't be immobile or anything. I'll think of something for you. Perhaps some wheels?
As I said, few things to make you my perfect pet.
Oh, you're struggling stop. Not yet.
I'll wait a little bit before we start the operation again. Aren't you excited?
Then, only then will you actually fully be mine. I can carve your name. I can carve my name.
In a little bit longer. Just wait. You can't wait, can you? I know. Being with me forever. That's a dream, isn't it? That's what you've always wanted. I can see it in your eyes.
This is what you've always wanted. You don't need anything else but me. I'll provide you everything. There's nothing more you could want.
I'll feed you, bathe you, and give you lots of love. Just be good. Listen to me. I'll pay all my orders. That's all you need.
You don't want anything else. If you do, I can provide.
I'm so happy you're here. I hope you're happy too. I bet you are.
The cage is there. You can't get out. I told you. It's not going to be possible to get out. Not unless I take you out myself.
Getting out? Are you thinking about getting out? You better not be. I've been so good to you. Why would you want to leave?
You're not going to leave, are you? You know what happens when you try to leave.
I'll have to put you down. And nobody wants that. Nobody wants to be put down.
If you want to leave, you have to leave everything behind. Everything. Your heart beat.
Your breath. Everything.
That's good. You're happy. That's all I want.
You want the kibble again? So needy.
All right.
Satisfied?
Of course a kiss.
Now, are you happy? Good. You're so happy.
I'm sorry that I can't play with you a little longer. I have some things to do. Is that okay?
As long as you're happy.
I apologize. I'll be back soon. If you like this, let me know. You can leave a comment or a like. And of course, don't forget to subscribe.
Any lullabies before I go?
Ah, yes. The likes and soupas. Give me a second.
Thank you for the $1 tip, Miss Morrigan. As soon as I saw what the stream was, I went and put my collar on. I was so glad to have you as an owner. I hope I was a good pet for you, a good girl. You are. You are. Don't worry. Thank you.
Thank you once again, Miss Morrigan, for the late.
You pour your into pet space so quickly, having my own collar with the bell on it made for just an immersive experience. I'm glad I got you your own collar in case you didn't.
Thank you for the $2 tip, Eileen. I'm genuinely considering adding a collar to my next Amazon order. It happened for the last week. Never had those thoughts before. This is your fault.
I hope you like being in control. I'm your master after all.
Thank you, Logan.
Serna, for the $10 super chat. I love Mercy. I love you too.
Thank you for the tip, $3 33 tip, Zyron. Absolute cinema. I'm glad I worked so hard to capture you and be my perfect little pet.
Thank you for the $2 super chat, Charlie. Go high. I came. Can I come out? I gotta go potty real bad. There's a little puppy pad in there. Go ahead. I'll clean it up.
Thank you for the $2 super chats. He's subtle. Good stuff. Go high. Got really into it. I'm glad.
Thank you for the $5 tip, Senpai. Folks, it happened. Now we are in the Discord kitten. I'm so glad after I've groomed you.
Thank you for the $690, Nicholas. Thank you for spending time with us and for the lovely stream. Please take care and have a fantastic evening. Thank you so much. I think I'll go rest.
But, as I said, Senpai, I had one more little surprise for you. Stay still, okay? This will only hurt for just a second.
Thank you for the $2 super chat. I'm glad I worked so hard to capture you and be my perfect little pet. Thank you for the $2 super chat. I'm glad I worked so hard to capture you and be my perfect little pet. Thank you for the $2 super chat. I'm glad I worked so hard to capture you and be my perfect little pet. Thank you for the $2 super chat. I'm glad I worked so hard to capture you and be my perfect little pet. Thank you for the $2 super chat. I'm glad I worked so hard to capture you and be my perfect little pet. Thank you for the $2 super chat. I'm glad I worked so hard to capture you and be my perfect little pet. Thank you for the $2 super chat. I'm glad I worked so hard to capture you and be my perfect little pet. Thank you for the $2 super chat. I'm glad I worked so hard to capture you and be my perfect little pet. Thank you for the $2 super chat. I'm glad I
worked so hard to capture you and be my perfect little pet. Thank you for the $2 super chat. I'm glad I worked so hard to capture you and be my perfect little pet. Thank you for the $2 super chat. I'm glad I worked so hard to capture you and be my perfect little pet. Thank you for the $2 super chat. I'm glad I worked so hard to capture you and be my perfect little pet. Thank you for the $2 super chat. I'm glad I worked so hard to capture you and be my perfect little pet. Thank you for the $2 super chat. I'm glad I worked so hard to capture you and be my perfect little pet. Thank you for the $2 super chat. I'm glad I worked so hard to capture you and be my perfect little pet. Thank you for the $2 super chat. I'm glad I worked so hard to capture you and be my perfect little pet. Thank you for the $2 super chat. I'm glad I worked so hard to capture you and be my perfect little pet.